[Music]
red andrews is known for being Archie's
dad but there's so much more to him than
meets the eye
sure he's a father but he's also a proud
member of the Riverdale community and a
hero in every sense of the word much
like everyone else in the show Fred went
through a serious character evolution
that rendered him even greater than
before
keep watching to see Fred Andrews
complete transformation he won't believe
how many differences there are between
the comics and the TV series Archie is a
comic book series that closely follows
The Adventures of teenagers Archie
Andrews Betty Cooper Veronica Lodge and
Jughead Jones this comic book has been
popular since the early 40s and has
continued to appeal to various
generations with hundreds of issues to
choose from fans of the series have
never had to scramble for new content so
when the CW was approached with the idea
of turning this legendary comic book
series into a TV show they immediately
got to work although many characters
were added to the franchise to create a
steady reality other characters were
revamped completely one of them being
Fred Andrews in the TV series were used
to seeing Betty and jugheads parents
however the comic books only showcase
parental figures like Fred and Mary
Andrews and Hyrum Lodge although fred
was present in both the comics and the
show his character underwent a huge
makeover he was given a fresh outlook
and a brand new family life and here's
where things get interesting while fred
is described as a super chill dad who's
always there for a son I meant your
music teacher last night yeah mrs.
Grundy this isn't exactly the case for
his comic book counterpart where as Luke
Perry's character was a construction
company owner comic book Fred is a
businessman who works in the automotive
industry
the original Frederick Andrews has
trouble seeing eye-to-eye with the
younger generation due to being
incredibly old-fashioned in fact some
might even describe Archie's dad as
bothered and conservative but this isn't
to say that Fred isn't a good father or
loving husband although he might have
trouble connecting with his sons Jenna
raishin that doesn't stop him from
trying he loves Archie more than
anything and the pair are quite close in
fact Fred and Archie are often seen
joking around in the comic book series
despite Fred's usual serious demeanor
underneath his cool calm and collected
exterior is a man with an extremely soft
heart and many of us were happy to see
that this last part was highlighted
throughout the TV series although the TV
series stayed true to the Archie
Duckhead Betty Ann Veronica's comic book
look the same can't be said about Fred's
because well they look nothing alike
like many comic book characters
Frederick is typically seen in the same
outfit which consists of tan dress pants
a white undershirt and a blue vest with
a vertical yellow design on it mr.
Andrews is also on the plump side and
has a hard time losing weight much to
his wife's dismay Fred is often seen
eating eggs and toasts and drinking
coffee in the comic book series as this
happens to be his favorite meal in
addition Fred's hair is black and thin
which is a very different hairdo than
the one New Age fans are used to in the
comics Fred's hair is thinning out and
is barely hanging on to the sides of his
head he's got a big and shiny bald head
that makes him look like the typical car
salesman he is for obvious reasons
Archie's dad isn't as present in the
comic books as he is in the TV series
but when he does show up he never fails
to teach Archaea valuable lesson despite
working as a businessman Fred likes to
brag about having many other skills
while he might work in a mid-level
management position
Fred feels as though he's not living up
to his full potential which is why he
wants to encourage his son to shoot for
the stars despite having some extra
weight on his frame Fred isn't someone
you want to mess with
in fact the character is known for
bragging about his strength and is said
to be stronger and more resourceful than
Archie himself in the comic books Fred
and Mary Andrews are happily married and
are often seen side-by-side however
money is tight and fred is typically
showcased trying to pinch every penny
that comes his way
[Music]
the comic book version of Fred Andrews
didn't receive a backstory so we were
delighted when Riverdale's Fred spoke
out about his upbringing Fred stories
and flashbacks helped us form a deeper
connection with his character quickly
turning him into a fan favorite much
like Archie fred was born and raised in
Riverdale where he attended the local
high school fred was best friends with
fp' Jones and ended up dating Hermione
Lodge for a short amount of time as a
teenager he was a talented baseball
player who also had a knack for music so
all in all Archie is every bit his
father's son Fred and f.p Jones formed a
band called the Fred heads in high
school which got them in in with the
ladies despite wanting to pursue a
professional career in either music or
sports
Fred's world came crashing down in his
junior year Fred's dad arty Andrews
unexpectedly passed away causing his son
to feel compelled to take over his
construction business Fred never got to
say goodbye to his dad which is
something we'll discuss at the end of
this video
Fred Andrews is a level-headed man who
always knows what to say to cheer up a
somber situation he's always a very
giving person which was clearly
showcased in season one when Fred gave
FP a construction job despite his better
judgement fred has a lot of pride which
he uses to perfect his work ethic
he's also an honourable man despite
having made some ethical mistakes
throughout the first season Fred chose
to give up his dreams to honor his
father's memory
he took over his construction business
and worked hard to maintain its revenue
after his father's passing
Fred met and married Mary after high
school and the couple soon had their
first and only son Archie unfortunately
there was trouble in paradise and mr.
and mrs. Andrews had a hard time being
in the same room together the tension
was so bad that Mary eventually moved
out of their family home to start a new
life in Chicago it's easy to see that
human Fred and cartoon Fred are two very
different people
unlike the comic book character fred is
a very attractive man who has a cool
demeanor about him the late Luke Perry
portrayed Fred Andrews on the CW TV
series Luke had always been known for
his stellar acting skills and solid
looks in fact he was once deemed as one
of the best-looking actors of his
generation so instead of having a
bulging guts thinning hair and a wacky
fashion sense fred was portrayed as a
middle-aged man with a muscular body and
a full head of brown hair on top of that
fred also had a full beard brown eyes in
a very casual wardrobe he was often seen
wearing flannel button-ups jeans and an
undershirt he stood at 5:10 and
regularly wore boots due to spending
most of his time on construction sites
on all Luke was the perfect person to
play Archie's dad in fact many people
believe that these two characters look a
lot alike
and one look at a side-by-side
comparison of the actors in their youth
is all we need to see to agree Fred had
a lot on his plate during the first
season of Riverdale not only with
Andrews construction coming up short in
the payroll departments but Archie was
seriously starting to act out Fred
quickly realized that his son was
sneaking out of the house and getting
into trouble so after seeing him with a
black eye he sat Archie down for a talk
despite having a love for music himself
Fred wasn't too supportive of Archie's
musical endeavors at first but after
seeing him play he chose to soundproof
the garage and stand by Archie's
decision everything became even more
complicated when his old flame Hermione
Lodge moved back into town on top of
that
Jason blossom had just been found dead
and a murder mystery was dividing
Riverdale things only seemed to get
worse when Alice Cooper told Fred that
Archie was sleeping with his teacher
miss Grundy on top of that Fred soon
found out the real reason Archie was
having trouble sleeping at night which
was due to having heard the gunshot that
allegedly killed Jason by Sweetwater
River by the end of season 1 Fred would
be fighting for his life after being
shot by the black hood at pop shop but
however extremely events of season 1 had
been this was only the beginning of
Fred's troubles
[Music]
Riverdale's first season ended with a
bang and many of us were desperate to
find out if Fred Andrews was going to
make it out alive although it was soon
confirmed that Fred would be regaining
consciousness fans couldn't help but
notice how much his near-death
experience changed him after undergoing
surgery fred was unable to breathe on
his own so he slipped into an
unconscious state where he battled some
of his inner demons it's here that we
got to see what Fred was really all
about instead of thinking about the
dreams he never accomplished or Hermione
Lodge Fred's subconscious revolved
around the only thing that really
mattered to him his son Archie he dreamt
of Archie's graduation day and we
showcased filming the events with a
happy Mary by his side throughout the
dream he kept repeating that he never
thought he'd get to witness his sons
graduation ceremony and sadly these
lines would later come back to haunt him
I think I'd love to see this day during
Fred's slumber he imagined the biggest
events in his son's life he pictured
Archie buy-in Veronica a ring and
proposing on top of that Fred got to
witness Archie and Veronica's wedding
day however his reverie was soon
interrupted by the black hood who tried
to take a shot at Archie these events
caused Fred to wake up he was greeted by
Archie who vowed to protect him from
that moment on however Fred revealed
that he'd only come back to protect
Archie not the other way around
Fred's near-death experience caused him
and married to grow closer together
whereas they used to have trouble being
in the same room they found comfort in
each other's presence although they
didn't get back together their entire
dynamic shifted in the right direction
The Andrews soon found out that miss
Grundy had been murdered and moose and
midge had been attacked in the woods
this said Archie to think that these
murders were connected but Fred was
skeptical of his son's beliefs Fred
began to realize that his son was his
own person and could formulate opinions
of his own so despite keeping a watchful
eye on Archie Fred learned to loosen his
grip on a son and respect his intuition
throughout the second season of
Riverdale we saw a major shift in Fred's
personality with the black hood still at
large it was only normal for Fred to be
frightened however nothing scared him
more
than his sons dedication to catch the
black hood and get his revenge
around this time Fred also began working
with the lodges and trying to improve
River Del's current situation
the lodges plan to flip the Southside
tearing it into a luxurious Eden and
while fred was on board at first he soon
began to see the truth
Hiram's arrival put an immediate end to
Fred and Hermione's relationship still
they had a very flirtatious way of
dealing with each other as the
jingle-jangle threat became more serious
Fred began to suspects that the
Southside wasn't the problem the lodges
were quick to state that the black hood
originated from the south side causing
an even bigger rift between the town
with FP & gell Fred took a bigger
interest in Jughead and warned Archie to
do the same
Fred's fatherly roots obviously extended
to his pals son and he was ready to bite
the bullet to guarantee his well-being
one of Fred's biggest challenges has
always had to do with finances and his
lifelong issue was brought to a whole
new level after receiving an eighty-six
thousand dollar bill from the hospital
at first Fred believed the drastic
amount to be a mistake but soon found it
to be factual unable to pay for his
house his company and the hospital bill
Fred's nerves began to get the best of
him luckily an angel donation was made
to his cause clearing his hefty debt
problem was the lodges had been behind
this donation which amplified Fred's
dealings with the crooked family to make
matters worse the FBI began poking their
heads into Fred's business demanding his
files for the last seven years after
things between the Andrews and the
lodges became too shady for his liking
Fred made the decision to separate ties
with the family breaking his so Dell
agreement in the process although Fred
had looks the other way many times
throughout the second season he ended it
in a righteous way instead of working
with sketchy people Fred chose to run
for mayor with hopes of changing
Riverdale for the better unfortunately
he would soon be bested by the lodges as
Hermione became their and Hyrum framed
Archie for murder although he'd meet a
dead end
Fred wasn't done fighting just yet
[Music]
Fred Andrews his third and final season
proved to be the most challenging one of
all not only was he forced to watch his
son get berated by a corrupted lawyer
but he was made to watch as the lodges
turned Riverdale into a crime infested
town despite being powerless against the
jury's verdict fred was still a powerful
man so when Hiram taunted his family
during the trial he didn't hesitate to
punch him in the face watching his son
lose his freedom was the hardest thing
Fred ever had to do and he blamed
himself for the events that led up to
the trial however Archie was quick to
explain that siding with Hyrum / Fred
was his own doing and that no one was to
blame but himself
despite Archie's imprisonments Fred
remains a hopeful man who is proud to be
an alleged murderers father in season 3
we finally get to see what Fred was like
in high school and we soon find out that
Archie's dad had some secrets of his own
as the youth in Riverdale becomes
infatuated with Griffin's and gargoyles
it's soon revealed that Fred was a
member of the Midnight Club as Riverdale
falls deeper and deeper into the
gargoyle Kings clutches Fred desperately
tries to free Archie from jail but
Archie soon escapes and explains to his
father that he can't return to Riverdale
it's here that Fred learns to let go and
respect Archie's wishes however he
doesn't want Archie to be alone so when
he finds out that Archie and Jughead her
visiting GLaDOS he drives up to see
Archie and gives him Vegas for moral
support although this may seem like a
small gesture it's actually huge
considering the dog is who helps Fred
with his own loneliness as many of you
know actor Luke Perry tragically passed
away on March 4th 2019 he last appear in
the episode chapter 50 American Dreams
in a twist of fate Archie will be losing
his father at 17 years old which was how
old Fred was when his own father passed
despite dreaming of watching his son
graduate and walked down the aisle this
is no longer possible Fred drastically
evolved in three short seasons he went
from being extra Stern to understanding
and a little crooked to righteous he
never lost hope in his son and was
always ready to lend a helping hand Luke
Perry's abroad
passing has devastated fans and loved
ones and many are curious to see if
Riverdale will honor his memory and
according to Cole Sprouse who plays
Jughead a few episodes have been
dedicated in his honor so what do you
guys think about Fred's evolution let us
know how you feel about the character in
the comments below and be sure to drop
some kind words about the late great
Luke Perry while you're at it give this
video a big thumbs up if you love river
del and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button for more character
evolutions like the swim thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]